la politique agricole commune est depuis
la fin des années 50 le ciment de la
construction européenne il faut qu'à
l'occasion de la prochaine négociation
sur la politique agricole commune qui
n'a pu aboutir à l'occasion de ce mandat
nous nous battions pour conserver des
ambitions qui doivent être les notes au
plan européen en matière de souveraineté
alimentaire de sécurité alimentaire de
modèle alimentaire il faut nous battre
pour que l'agriculture française et
européenne reste un fleuron de notre
économie
européenne nous devons protéger les
revenus des producteurs nous devons leur
donner de la lisibilité de façon à ce
que cette politique qu'il va falloir
redessiné soit une politique qui
garantisse notre autonomie alimentaire
la capacité des agriculteurs de tirer un
revenu de leur travail du fruit de leur
travail
mais l'agriculture et la politique
agricole commune ne se borne pas à ça
moi j'ai l'ambition que notre
agriculture soit la première solution à
la transition écologique
il n'y a pas d'opposition entre
agriculture et écologie
nous devons avoir un projet agricole
économiquement viable
environnementalement responsables et
socialement acceptable
nous devons redonner à l'agriculture
française et à l'agriculture européenne
toutes ses couleurs c'est notre fierté
notre modèle alimentaire français et
européens que nous vous devons
aujourd'hui défendre dans le concert de
la mondialisation